[Music]
this chromium plated sword is one of
thousands of identical pieces forged by
the chin Arsenal's more than two
thousand years ago they worked with a
precision unknown in Europe trigger
mechanisms and arrows for the crossbows
were manufactured in runs of tens of
thousands these massive arrowheads had
fearsome penetrating power
there could be no doubting the effect
they would have on enemy forces the Qin
military machine is deployed with just
one aim attack
at about this time rome had mustered
80,000 troops to counter the threat from
Hannibal but the king of Qin sent 1
million soldiers against his enemies
towns are besieged
bravery is prized above all when a chin
soldier is killed it's up to his fellows
to avenge his death
the penalty for cowardice is summary
execution
like a dog playing with a crippled hair
that's our one eyewitness described an
attack by the Qin army
the king of Chin's revolution claims
more than two million lives
the old feudal order with its concepts
of honor and mercy had passed into
history chins officers and promotion to
success on the battlefield not through
family status bring me the head of an
enemy soldier and you will advance by
one rank that was the maximum by which
chin soldiers were trained and by which
they lived and fought
the Honorable way to treat prisoners was
now to execute them and that meant
burying them alive
if we believe the accounts 400,000 enemy
soldiers were dispatched in this way
even today China still can't agree
whether the ends justify the means for
some the king of Qin is the cruelest of
despots others see him as the father of
the nation who swept away the feudal
States with a single stroke
[Music]